hmm do you think so too yeah do about it
hold off I wonder
you
it began as a simple investigation of
some bizarre murders in the suburbs of
Raccoon City nothing in our training
could ever have prepared us for the
nightmare that ensued
never stood a chance
failure emergency landing
Oh
check the current position and
investigate the surrounding area captain
look
captain hmm what happened court order
for transportation prisoner Billy Cohen
X lieutenant 26 years old
court-martialed and sentenced death july
twenty second prisoners to be
transferred to the rageth on base for
execution those poor soldiers there were
good men just doing their jobs and that
scum murdered them and escaped all right
everyone let's separate and survey the
area our friend is brutal and ruthless
keep your guard up
a train
this is officer chambers from stars
Bravo Team please identify yourself is
someone there
Billy lieutenant Cohen so you seem to
know me been fantasizing about me have
you you're the prisoner that was being
transferred for execution you are with
those soldiers outside oh I see you're
with stars well no offense honey but
your kind doesn't seem to want me around
so I'm afraid our little chat time is
over wait you're under arrest no thanks
Dollface I've already warned handcuffs I
could shoot you know
Edward are you all right what happened
worse than you can't you must be careful
Rebecca
the forest is full of zombies and
monsters zombies and monsters this is
rebekah over enrico hello can you read
me please respond three people
enrico captain hello hello it's gonna be
dangers from here on in why don't we
cooperate cooperate with you listen
little girl if you haven't noticed
there's some pretty freaked out things
on this train and I for one want to get
out of here I don't think we stand a
chance doing it alone you expect me to
trust you a wanted felon I don't need
your help I can handle this on my own
and don't call me little girl all right
miss do it yourself what should I call
you the name is Rebecca chambers but
that's officer chambers to you well then
Rebecca why don't you go and try while I
wait here
um excuse me sir sir
are you okay
who is that guy